so let's get started with the usual
adopting the agenda no problem about
that I guess with the usual
announcements as to the linguistic
conditions of our work which I am
escaping and them
no endorsements
of appointment by the coordinators this
time and the usual chapter of delegated
acts and implementing acts which I am
also escaping for the sake of time
saving so that we move right
to the first point
in the order of the day which is legal
migration
skills Hi how are you doing
and talent package
you know that migration is one of the
most relevant policy and law making
fields of action
and we have a point on legal migration
we're always insisting on legal and safe
five ways to the European Union so that
we crack down on the business model of
illicit trafficking of human beings
Smugglers
to regular migration
needs Progressive replacement for legal
migration Talent package
now
there are
mandates on the latest commission
proposals published last April
Levy
our committee
is making a point on keeping legal
migration in the center of our attention
we have been working hard on the common
European Asylum system with a new
balance
now
we are approaching the trilogs with the
council
and we have an expectation of having the
the work done and deliver
on the matter
but then we are also discussing
from the point of view of demography
and economy 2
how to enhance
legal Pathways legal migration tools
which are to be discussed today
that is the only way
to keep up with some other regions as
the case of America or Australia which
have
strong legal migration tools
and that is why we have put in place
single permit long-term residence
directive among other instruments we had
adopted in the first man dating Richard
of the committee including seasonal
workers posted workers
and
we're having today
some
ground for discussion on the reports
which are ongoing as to the cast
procedures that I've just mentioned
we have a
couple of panels
from now onwards
the first panel is inviting Professor
Steve Pierce which is accompanying here
in the side of the podium Essex
University
he will be speaking for eight minutes
and then it'll be there is a hornung
German business Business Association and
business Europe
which will be taking the floor also for
seven minutes
and I suggest after having heard
from this first panel we open the floor
with a
with the representatives of the
political group there will be a first
round of two minutes
questionings
and then some two minutes to respond
from the side of our panelist
if I'm not mistaken there will be a
third panelist in the first round yes in
the first round there is the third
panelist Michelle Levoy from bikum NGO
Corporation platform for undocumented
migrants also for seven minutes but
let's go one by one now it'll be first
Professor Pierce everyone is yours seven
minutes
okay thank you very much it's always a
pleasure to to be invited here to talk
about uh immigration issues and
um I'm going to focus on what the
commission's paper calls the
forward-looking pillar the uh three
ideas for future legislation before I
mention them it's also important to
mention the uh plans coming earlier for
a proposal on a talent pool I think it
would be important to scrutinize that
from a data protection point of view and
uh efficiency point of view to see that
it's a a useful contribution to
obtaining Labor uh from uh non-eu
citizens and secondly there there will
be a proposal on recognition of
qualifications
which will again be quite useful it will
particularly ensure that Third Country
Nationals with qualifications outside
the EU
recognized in the U have have capacity
to work uh in in member states perhaps
at the level of their training and
expertise so you know a doctor won't uh
be a taxi driver if they have the
capacity to uh to work as a doctor
um so on the
three proposals
this work yes um so it in the
communication the commission mentions
long-term care workers youth mobility
and an innovation visa and possibly
other proposals on other low or medium
paid workers
um but I'll focus on long-term care
workers because perhaps that's easier to
fit into the existing legal framework of
paid labor migration
um now the study for the European
Parliament suggested adding long-term
care way workers
to the blue card law that's already in
place
um there are different ways to do this
you could add it to the single permit
directive or it could be a separate law
but either way the same issues will
arise so well uh you know look at this
the blue card by way of example
so um is it first of all the same scope
of people do you elect refugees who are
now covered by the blue card law apply
uh or not do you exclude the same people
who are excluded by the blue card law uh
do you include the same people who are
included by it or do you have some
different question as to who is covered
I think it's particularly important to
ask if beneficiaries of temporary
protection would be included especially
if the current temporary protection for
the Ukraine invasion is extended because
then we'll have a lot of people on the
territory who might want to transfer
their status when temporary protection
ends
so as with the single permit directive
and others uh that's an important
question whether you exclude that
category of people now
um
let's see um
another question is whether you need
special admission criteria above and
beyond what we already have for the blue
card directive
um another question is uh whether to
keep a labor market quota possibility
for member states that has to remain
because the treaty requires it but do
you keep a labor market preference test
do you keep an ethical recruitment
exception which is in the blue card law
I would suggest yes but um you know you
could discuss that and then what happens
in the event of unemployment
or if you want to change jobs so that
was a difficult negotiation under the
blue card directive I think it's about
to be a difficult negotiation for the
single permit directive where the
council and Parliament have different
views on those issues
um so uh I imagine there there could be
a debate about that and if you go with
the blue card rules of three months or
six months worth of unemployment
um that's more generous than what the
council thinks should be the case for a
single permit hold so it will be
important of course which which approach
is chosen
uh another question is whether to have a
standard period of validity uh is the
idea that uh care workers would only be
coming for a short period of a year or
two perhaps possibly renewable perhaps
even sent home after that or do you give
flexibility uh to member states to
decide that so are we treating them like
seasonal workers or treating them like
someone
um who has the possibility of long-term
residents as blue card holders or
researchers would do of course if you're
wanting to attract people to the
European Union it makes more sense to uh
have a longer period of validity but
also be a question do you accept
in-country applications for people who
are here legally on another basis do you
have rules limiting fees not just by
administrations but on what employers
charge workers which can be very high
fees for recruitment in this field do
you have a fast track for selected
employers
do you have a deadline to consider
applications if so what is it that's
something which the Parliament and the
council have often argued about uh
before
um
uh I've already mentioned what happens
if there's a change of employer another
question will be equal treatment
um whether you have the same rules on
employment and here I have to correct
the study that was done for the European
Parliament that says working time
directive does not apply to Third
Country Nationals and in fact there's
nothing in the working time directive to
exclude Third Country Nationals
um uh if you look at the footnotes the
study confuses two different directives
and the court of justice in the case I
list that tumor has said that another EU
employment law applies not only to Third
Country Nationals but even to Third
Country Nationals who are not legally
residents they get employment law
protection under EU law does it change
their immigration status but they do
have employment law protection
um and then finally I mean I won't have
time to comment on the other two
proposals
um the questions will arise do you have
a derogation from the family reunion
directive which has been negotiated for
the blue card some of the measures uh if
so what exactly because long-term care
workers might want obviously to bring
their family with them
um and uh you know do you uh make things
uh easier not having to have a prospect
of permanent residence uh and so on and
do you have derogations also from the
long-term residence directive as some
other EU legislation does uh to make it
perhaps easier to be a long-term
resident at least to confirm that
long-term care workers can be an EU
long-term resident because that may be
an important factor in whether they they
wish to come to work in the European
Union
so thanks very much and I look forward
to the discussion
thank you for your presentation
Professor Pierce now let's hear from
Theresa hornung floor is yours seven
minutes thank you so much uh dear chair
dear members of parliament committee
um many thanks for inviting me to
today's hearing on the way forward and
legal my creation and I'm glad to have
the chance to bring in some of the ideas
and thought of the employers
um I'm from the German employers however
I will also represent business Europe
and the entire EU business Community
today
the EU business community supports a
holistic skilled labor strategy in which
labor migration of course forms one
crucial pillar
so the quick question is how can we
better attract and retain Talent from
abroad
anyone who wants to come
to work in Europe today
um is faced with a bureaucratic jungle
um we need to make the administrative
procedures as well as legal framework
more attractive more customer oriented
we need a simpler faster but also more
digital administrative procedures
and especially the long waiting times at
for the Visa appointments need to need
to come to an end and of course that's
that's all national responsibility right
we're talking about National authorities
however the EU can and already does set
um binding requirements here when it
comes to guaranteed processing time
so one part of course to tackle current
shortcomings and gaps is stronger
enforcement of directives and we have
pretty much seven directives that govern
the admission to and residents in the EU
for Third Country Nationals
another important part is information
campaigns to actually make Third Country
Nationals aware of all the procedures in
place because most of the time they just
don't know
and of course we also need legislative
measures to tackle inconsistencies and
that's what I focus on today
a lot of good work has been done already
by both the European commission and the
Parliament and I really want to say that
in all clarity
we have
um a very well revised clue cut
directive so now we just need to aim for
an ambition ambitious National
transposition of that directive
we have the recast of the single permit
directive congrats Mr Sanchez and
Conquest to Damien for the long-term
residence directive
I do hope for for good and ambitious try
look results here so fingers crossed
and but the question is of course what's
up next and um yeah I would like to make
four points
first the European talent pool and um
as we currently discuss with the
European commissions and the different
policy options and it's quite likely
that we it will be a legislative option
I took the liberty to to include it
um into this part of the panel
so an u-wide talent pool that allows
employers but also very importantly
public employment services to few
um to post vacancies and allow Third
Country job Seekers to view them and
then to actually facilitate a matching
um that has in our opinion a lot of
potential
of course this can only be successful if
the talent pool is of added value and
that's what we're all working on quite
intensely right now
it should be simple for all involved
actors and we need to avoid parallel
structures and possibly most importantly
it needs to allow for technical
inter-operationality with national
systems and tools
there are a lot of questions like where
now it's really the the nitty-gritty
part that that counts and and will be
decisive for for the success of the
talent pool we could of course start
with a gradual like it could be a
credible approach in which we start with
a focus on like sectors of indeed
strategic relevance to our European
labor market so talking about shortage
sectors
um but I think in the long term it will
be less bureaucratic and also um will
cost less resources to actually have a
broad approach of a talent pool open to
all kinds of sectors
so those are the thoughts very broadly
on on the talent pool
um the other one
is
how can we better harness the potential
of foreign founders
we do face and I I I mostly talk about
Germany right now but I'm sure it's an
an issue in other member states as well
um we have issues attracting
non-european startups
then
when it comes to the procedures
um you it's often that authorities
require
um documents that are actually not
provided for by law they want outdated
documentation and so on so
often there are still legal hurdles but
mostly hurdles and and practice and if
we want Europe and we talk about
Innovation all the time if we want
Europe within intranarial Spirit then
that entrepreneurial Spirit also needs
to be reflected in our legislation
and in our administrations and in our
society and and so far it isn't
so we as a business Community would like
to advocate for a special European
startup visa for Founders
um it would be a strong signal to all
talented people about worldwide that
their ideas here in Europe are welcome
and the question is of course how could
that look like
um it should be simple and quick to to
to implement it should create attractive
framework conditions
and member states could be asked to
establish Central National bodies for
example that evaluate and coordinate the
business plans that advise on funding
opportunities
um but most importantly which isn't the
case right now
um that the submission of business
business plans is also possible in
English but also that the actual
application procedure the information
the guidance that all that is also
available in English I think there we we
Face a lot of shortcomings in most
member states
my third point is the EU family
reunification directive
so we had a lot of um quite a few
recasts and revisions so far and we do
believe that this one needs one too
um because it is quite outdated it
doesn't directly promote increased labor
market participation of family members
so I think here we really need to
simplify the the requirements for and
examination of an application for family
reunification
we need a much faster notification
periods for the competent authorities I
mean right now it's nine months
that's the blue card is there we have
immediate labor market excess of family
members
um the ICT directives it's up to 90 days
and here we talk about nine months
that's
ridiculous
so in general
um we need
also less bureaucratic procedures and
and here I'm talking also about labor
market tests because it can take up to
one year for family members until they
have Labor Market access
which in terms of Labor shortages is
maybe not the smartest thing
and I'm getting to my last point and
that is indeed the recognition of
foreign qualifications and there we have
an upcoming proposal by the commission
and this autumn and here I just want to
emphasize
the formal recognition of qualifications
in non-regulated occupations it should
not be mandatory we shouldn't make it
here so complicated
um in in in in most cases we can carry
out also qualification measures in the
company on the ground which is often so
much easier than doing it all free
pre-arrival
um and when it comes to regulated
professions and I know that's a more
sensitive topic we need to accelerate
and and simplify procedures and hear
also some unbureaucratic skills
assessment might be
um interesting to to talk about and so
I'm looking forward to the upcoming
legislation here and I think the the
guidelines on on the recognition of
Ukrainian qualifications issued by the
commission last year is is also um maybe
an inspiring example to look at how we
can actually if there's political will
make make things easy and less
bureaucratic
so um let me close by saying
um a welcome culture really begins in
our administrations it's in it begins in
the Visa offices of our foreign missions
um as well as after migration and of
course it until it extends to
um
our entire social life
and I think that welcome culture is
something
that needs to be the guiding principle
um for the way we make laws and I think
that we still have some some space thank
you
we thank you
now let's hear from Michelle Levoy which
is our third panelist seven minutes and
then we will start the discussion one by
one political groups okay there you go
thank you sure
um first of all speaker we definitely
welcome the European parliament's
commitment to regular migration but
there I want to say we can we welcome to
regular migration we actually as pikm
use the UN terminology which talks about
regular safe and orderly migration it
doesn't talk about legal migration and
the reason being is because if I say
legal you will probably automatically
think of the opposite illegal and this
is what we're trying to avoid is these
terms that actually create stigma and
criminalization
so going forward I actually wanted to
start off with narratives because I
think what we continuously hear the
chair mentioned and in the opening why
is the EU embarking on this path to also
make the EU competitive we saw the world
bank issue last week the world
development report from 2023 where the
narrative is once again about regular
migration but we as peacom are a little
bit concerned that some of the
narratives at the EU level actually
around attracting talents and the focus
on workers skills levels don't really
fully reflect the realities of Labor
migration because there are workers and
many crucial sectors for economies that
are considered low-skilled like care
we've heard agri-food Hospitality
Construction
uh workers who are not well protected
and yet a lot of sectors rely on the
presence of these workers but there's
not a lot of possibilities to do this
regularly
um and many migrant workers are pushed
to work irregularly and take Undeclared
jobs so in my input now I just want to
highlight some key points on the single
permit and the long-term residence
directive and then briefly at the end on
the talent pools but key points where we
think in terms of the parliament's
position and the negotiations going
forward it's crucial to retain some of
the things that have already been
adopted so the first one on the single
permit uh the scope article 3 we fully
embrace the position of the parliament
to include categories which have so far
been excluded from the single permit so
to include seasonal workers to include
Au pairs beneficiaries of national forms
of protection and beneficiaries of
temporary protection and the right to
change employer on article 11
this right is key for workers to be able
to more easily stand up for their rights
to challenge exploitation and leave
abuse of employment the way that it's
been adopted now in the parliament with
the subject to the mandatory
notification procedure is fine obviously
but we can't have this be cumbersome or
burdensome on workers so it's crucial
going forward when it's negotiated that
it's not considered kind of a new formal
application we're a little concerned
with the council's position which would
allow member states to require an
application for the worker to change
employer and to set a minimum time
period before a change of employer is
permissible this would actually make the
rights to change employer unworkable in
practice and could lead to Too Much
flexibility for member states and uneven
rules across the EU on the period of
unemployment article 11 this is crucial
because we don't want to see situations
where job loss would lead to the loss of
the permit and that would be make people
become undocumented so we're very much
in support of the the parliament
proposal to introduce a period of job
search of nine months which is in line
with directive 2016 and the right to
information and procedural guarantees
articles 9 and 11. this is key to
upholding workers rights so this is
concerning not only the length of the
procedures but also the possibility for
permit applicants or workers to change
employer to start working while they
wait for the authorities to process
their application
here I wanted to highlight a case that
we've collected as part of research that
we're doing on the single permit
application as it is now in three
countries in Belgium the Czech Republic
in Spain that we're doing with the ulb
equality law clinic and This concerns a
case of an individual who completed a
master's degree in Belgium and who later
obtained a one-year job-seeking permit
during this period he found a job he was
offered a permanent contract but when
his job Seeker permit expired his
employer applied for a single permit on
his behalf he received the first
rejection after four months which is the
maximum time National authorities have
to give a response but when he lodged an
appeal he had to wait more than seven
months without a response before his
appeal was dismissed and during that
time period he couldn't work so he
endured a total total of nearly a year
of waiting without work which obviously
caused significant hardships and the
other issue is monitoring facilitation
of complaints article 13-14 very much
welcomed the parliament proposal to
extend the single permit for 12 months
for migrant workers who are victims of
serious violations of their rights to
find an alternative job with full access
to the labor market and we also think it
would be good that member states make
better use of existing permits for
example under the anti-trafficking and
employers sanctions directive Frameworks
and the second point on the long-term
residence directive
we very much welcome the EU EP support
to the proposal to lower the state and
the EU for three years instead of five
with one year of stay in the member
State when the person applies and these
would also be important points to keep
in the negotiation stage and the trial
logs so the possibility to have
interruptions between residence permits
so for example if someone becomes
undocumented and doesn't have continuous
State and interruptions between work
contracts
important to keep
evaluation of quote regular resources
should take into account all types of
social assistance and protection
measures the person's entitled to by
national law but the inclusion of
certain types of assistance by the
parliament is an important step in the
right direction and should also be kept
in Children of EU long-term residence
permits should be granted a permit
irrespective a place of birth and
without other requirements and the
autonomous permit for family member so
not only spouses should become automatic
after two years and possibly after one
year as in the parliament position and
finally briefly on the talent
Partnerships in the talent pool and the
talent Partnerships in general we feel
that if public EU funds and resources
will support labor migration schemes in
particular they should at the minimum
include additional safeguards to ensure
migrants rights a good Administration
overall and on the talent pool we do
have some doubts as to the effectiveness
of it because improving recruitment will
not solve the question of the admission
of workers and the lack of decent labor
migration Pathways
member states now actually have a
patchwork of Labor migration policies
and having the new single permit would
be a more horizontal solution for
workers to come to Europe so we actually
see the value added of the talent pool
would be to promote Fair recruitment
standards a lot of this work has already
done by the international labor
organization but there that's linked to
the quality of permits so just to
conclude where we recommend some
principles for the talent pool would be
transparency and participation
participation of all stakeholders this
means trade unions Civil Society
organizations with migrants should be
involved at all stages alongside the
private sector we should also take into
consideration different income levels
skills and labor sectors and look
particularly at sectors which currently
have high levels of exploitation and
finally the lack of information is one
of the key gaps in labor existing and
labor migration Pathways so we need to
make sure that people are fully
understood of their rights not only at
the recruitment stage but then
afterwards as well thank you
Lavoy thinks are three panelists in this
first round for discussion now suggest
considering that there are three and you
are going to be given the floor one by
one political group for two minutes I
suggest they take note of the questions
that you are about to raise so that they
have a common round to respond okay
it'll be two minutes every political
group first floor to get on learners
but thank you chair and thank you to all
three of the the panelists has been a
pleasure listening to you it's a bit a
little bit old in the timing because of
course lots of the work on the on both
of the pieces of legislation has been
done already but it's good to hear your
uh your support for the positions of the
parliament and and the the inspiration
surely that our two reporters have have
gotten also for the the upcoming uh try
logs
um a couple of of short questions
um
uh Mr Pierce first of all I'm a big fan
of your blog uh so it's good to meet you
here in person and I remember and I know
it's a long time ago so forgive me if I
paraphrase it completely wrongly but I
remember around the times of brexit you
once wrote A Blog where you said that
even though there is a there is a sound
economic argument for freedom of
movement within the European Union and
there's there's full support for it
there's also a political and a societal
context which meant that even
pro-europeans should consider being a
bit tougher on free movement in order to
maintain it for the future uh I was
listening to the debate today as well
and everybody is very positive about the
added value of regular migration to to
stick to the The Narrative uh do you see
the the same risks there because I think
indeed there are sound economic
Arguments for making legal migration
easier for for having more legal
migration in the European Union but at
the same time we see that it is a hugely
divisive policy uh political discussion
in many of our member states
particularly in the context of uh of
increasing numbers of irregular arrivals
um uh in the European Union uh reaching
the numbers of of the crisis years
already how do you see this this
distension between the sound economic
arguments but also the the many concerns
that there are in our societies when it
comes to uh migration as such secondly
on the recognition of qualifications I
come from across border region in the
Netherlands and we see that even
recognition of qualifications uh within
the European Union even between
sometimes very similar member states can
be hugely problematic which which very
very bureaucratic
problems for the persons involved how do
you envision this and this goes to all
three of you for for having this
recognition of qualifications with with
third uh Third Country Nationals if even
within the European Union we still
sometimes fail to do it in a um in in in
an effective way you mentioned more
digital procedures less bureaucracy Etc
maybe if you could elaborate a little
bit on yes and how do we make sure
you're someone skeptical about the
talent pools uh but I think maybe one of
the the good ideas of that Talent was
that it also increases access for
smaller companies how do we ensure that
that when we talk about Labor migration
from third countries it's not only uh
something that that big companies in the
European Union can benefit from but also
that those smes that are in need of a
skilled Workforce can benefit in the
same way thank you
you think of Jerome now it'll be for the
s d Javier Moreno
gracias thank you very much indeed
German and good afternoon everyone first
of all
can I thank our guests
I'll just give them a chance to put
their headsets on I wish to thank them
for their presentations we as
legislators have to do our work here and
we very much rely on contributions from
the academic world but also from Civil
Society
and Miss Levoy I think you're quite
right on that point you made about the
narrative we have to change the
narrative and whether or not we talk
about regular irregular what have you we
need to change the perception around the
issue of migration we know that
there are certain political forces that
uh seem to be breeding fear and worries
in order to score points and get votes
when the reality is far from that and
the reality is more positive and I think
the real instrument to manage irregular
migration is
to have an instrument and whatever we
wish to call that is another point
what we have right now is a patchwork of
legislation seven directives and is
strong difficult to make sure that
everything's coherent I was a reperto on
the blue card uh directive now um the
Raptor on the single permit and it's
true the European Parliament has
ambitious
proposals and we've been working very
well across the political
groups and now the next stage is to try
and reach an agreement with Council I
don't know whether the council have
organized these kinds of hearings with
you but I think it's very important that
we get Council on board
and that we can get them on board with
the commission proposal and have a good
outcome because there's one concern that
we have on equal treatment and
respective migrants rights
but
the real needs of our businesses and is
another point that you very rightly made
the real needs in the business community
that they are going to rely on these
migrants
and of course the member states will
want to keep some degree of control but
smes all sized businesses
I really need this Workforce
and a final point I think is very
important that we work together on
information and provision there's no
point in having the best possible
directive if no one's aware of it and
that has to be something that we make
sure happens in uh origin countries
Transit countries and destination
countries we need to really ask Council
to organize information event
information campaigns and through NGO
civil society as well
we know that their work is crucial in
this field and I think I'll stop here
because I could speak for hours on these
topics thank you Mr Moreno on the renew
group it'll be IC which is al-salani Mrs
salsalani there you go
thank you Mr chair and I think you are
your guests for being here it was very
interesting listening to you and also
confirming uh many of the uh information
and the
knowledge that we already have but also
enriched our perspectives with new
knowledge and perspectives
um I worked
on the parliament inl report on legal
labor migration as well as long-term
residence directive along with Mr
boslager here and also on the single
format directive so I have approached
the label migration from many uh
perspectives and on on different
legislations I have
[Music]
a trouble making some of the political
groups here understand that the EU is
not the most attractive region for skill
competence to come to we still believe
we have this self imagery of being the
most attractive place to come to when in
reality we are competing with both the
US Canada and Oceania about the skilled
labor migration but also the lower skill
level migration and this is actually
causing us big troubles because in
Sweden almost all uh branches all
businesses or types of businesses
sectors are saying that they are not
being able to actually recruit from home
there are not enough people with the
certain needed set of skills that they
can have so their businesses can Thrive
and also in that way
contribute to our welfare so I have
actually two questions the first one is
the the
integration
issue we are asking for
um to have integration uh
musts in the second member State because
we do believe that making EU more
attractive is also about making EU
intramobility possible and with that
means that your rights have to be
portable so if you already have a
demands on integration in the first
member State and then you get a find a
job in the second member State as a
labor migrant do you believe that the
demands on integration in the second
member state will actually hinder the
intra-eu mobility for labor migrants
and my second question is about the
talent pools
well uh the representative from picom
was a little bit skeptical but in my
mind the talent pool were was a way to
make the EU labor market accessible even
for a refugee in Kenya who who has you
know fled fled for example the war in
Sudan and have a smartphone so they can
access the talent pool but the issue is
how can we make it easier for the
validation of the skills not only the
diplomas because diplomas is one thing
skills is another thing do you have any
ideas about how can how can we make it
doable and more also user-friendly both
for the labor migrant but also for the
employer when it comes to the validation
of the skills thank you so much okay
exceeded somewhat your timing but you've
been
sharing and racing a number of questions
which certainly are going to be
responded by the panelists let's follow
now with the greens I understand it will
be Damian boselager
yes thank you chair and thank you
everyone for coming in your interesting
interventions
um Professor Pierce you were talking
about the long-term care workers and um
actually under the leadership we try to
get that into the blue cards um sadly
didn't work but I'm wondering now do you
think it even makes sense to write
another sector legislation just
specifically for this group of people is
this what you would support or would you
rather say that we should try to you
know include them into existing
legislation even though that might make
take more time so just to hear your
opinion on that more clearly would be
very interesting
thanks for mentioning the transposition
I think that's crucial and I have a lot
of thoughts on the utan pool but I'll
just ask a couple of questions uh the
first one being
you talked about a sector versus broad
approach um if we think about what we
also just said in terms of communication
of the utahn pool to Third Country
Nationals does it make sense to have a
sector approach where you basically go
on the home page and then they say sorry
it's not for you or should we just have
one you know homepage for everyone a
broad approach saying Hey I want to work
in the EU this is who I am and wouldn't
it make it from a communication site
more easily and then that's more like
another question about how do you set up
a talent pool that it doesn't crowd out
um private offerings like LinkedIn other
you know matching platforms how can you
integrate the private sector into the
matching of the talents
um
and then the foreign Founders happy to
discuss this uh more I think that sounds
like an interesting idea to follow up
Mrs Lavoy um yeah I always talk about
Labor migration I don't know if that
falls in the right category or or not
um in terms of a wording for me I would
be interested to understand how you see
your role in the talent pool what would
be things that you would like to
contribute in this matching process
um I think you mentioned uh potential
you know standards and ethical
recruitment but it would be interesting
to understand how you would see that
technically happening thank you
thank you now for ID I understand
it'll be Mr Vantage or we can buyers
with survivors but nutrition who is
making it for the Friday you Tom
validation or you Mr Rhymes is not yet a
member of idea
I'm sorry I'm sorry Mr CCR then it'll be
you Tom
ECR is normally first then
two minutes
thank you uh chair uh now uh my Epp
colleague stated that he would respect
the official narrative on irregular
migration so I will be the boy in The
Emperor's New Clothes
um pointing out that if you enter EU
territory in a way that breaks the law
we're talking about committing an
illegal act so legal migration is the
term I prefer to use
so uh what I would like to uh ask is
about the long-term residence report
recently endorsed by the EU Parliament I
want to ask Professor Pierce about it
there this report was adopted only a few
months after frantics reported the
highest numbers of illegal entries to
the EU since 2016. 330
000 in 2022 so one would think that
migration proposals would be carefully
designed so as not to strengthen pull
factors for illegal migration because
the frontix report indeed confirms that
existing pull factors for illegal
migration to the EU are indeed very
strong today
the parliament in this report now
proposes that the rules for acquiring
long-term residency should be amended so
that the required period of residence
for the acquisition of EU long-term
resident status is reduced from five to
three years
and that the entire period of time
between the date of the lodging of the
application for international protection
and the date of the granting of the
status of beneficiary of protection be
considered as residency it also removes
the irrigations regarding equal
treatment issues such as access to
public housing and to employment
reserved for EU citizens as well as all
integration conditions for joining
family members my question to you
Professor is whether this policy if
implemented is more likely to decrease
or increase incentives for illegal
migration to the EU thank you very much
okay now it'll be ID Thomas Edition
thank you for visiting
um the his hidden is from the arbex is
um
when we talk about Labor migration
things really got going in the 60s and
70s in my country and in Germany and it
really led to some form of Multicultural
chaos now migration labor migration
there are reasons behind this why do
people come from Morocco and other
countries to Europe quite simply because
the costs of Labor were reaching such
levels
that
there was a need to bring those costs
down
the truth is that a new liberal
neocolonial uh
streets being replayed raw materials are
being exploited first and now what we're
seeing is human resources being
exploited in a way people are being
brought over
there's also another issue open borders
just doesn't work if you look at
Flanders in the Netherlands
40 to 50 percent
um
non-europeans actually are not in work
they're not
um
on the active labor market whereas many
of the people from Ukraine for example
and so if that's something we have to
bear in mind and look at Japan
um Automation
and Tech were the solutions that were
pursued and look at Hungary for example
that they want um
a birth rate policy so I think there's a
narrative on migration
where
that's there's all this debate about
irregular versus regular migration
whether criminal acts are being
[Music]
rebranded irregular do we have irregular
rape do we have irregular burglary
surely I mean I'd like to ask the
speakers on the top table
do you believe that the Millions
of people you bring wish to bring to
Europe annually
and regular
labor migration
isn't that just going to further
exacerbate the problems we have already
in our societies and really sowing all
these divides looking for a
representative yeah I know your point of
order surely yes and the speaker just
also referred to me so he also knows and
he's doing it on purpose but chair
I would actually like there to be
because this is the umpteenth time that
he is using far-right extremist language
in this committee and each time it's me
asking for the floor maybe it's time
that the the leadership of this
committee would respond to this
okay because we shouldn't normalize this
and it's getting normalized if we don't
respond it's far right language
just saying
freedom of speech is really what a
democracy far-right extremist language
consider your speech extremist
Sophie let me make clear
of course I do have my own assessments
my own opinions
about things I hear
this time with the help of the
translation to say we regularly follow
live every speech but when it comes to
Flemish I use translation
the only point I can make is that this
is a house this is a realistic house and
yes they are extreme right
there are extreme right seats in this
house yes
I
have my own opinion and my own
assessments but it's not for the
presidency of the European Parliament or
the care of a committee
to interfere with the points that are
made
on the representation of the
constituents
much as I dislike
things I hear
this is a house
in which points are to be heard of are
to be argued about
you have every right to oppose
everything you hear
but as to the members expressing their
views I think this is the way chair
racism is not an opinion
excuse me racism is a criminal offense
if if you say I I'm a perpetrator of a
criminal offense then we will meet each
other in court
I have repeatedly asked for the Bureau
of this committee to look into it
well you made your point
now let's proceed okay let's go I was
looking for the left representation
which I don't see regrettably so I don't
see see any other representative you
will be having a flop I can understand
there are some other members also
willing to contribute to the discussion
it'll be now honorable Pietro Bartolo
of course
I should like to uh thank the speakers
and all the work that they have done on
this issue which we are looking at
and of course many of the elements in
this uh debater I don't share
we've had the comments which have been
made by uh
our colleague
from the writer
and uh I think that uh
it's important that we do challenge what
is being said
now what we are looking at is irregular
or regular migration legal or illegal
migration migration becomes illegal when
we deem that somebody has arrived in an
irregular fashion
what we want is somebody to come by
regular routes
and of course what we also have to look
at are the human traffickers and the
importance of tackling those who are
trafficking in human beings so
these are people who are trafficking
human beings and what we want is the
sort of people who are coming in to be
able to come in in a regular fashion
when they Merit it to
so this discussion on uh irregular
migrants economic migrants
Etc is one thing but I do think that
that what we are working on and I think
we have to look at this along this lines
the single permit the blue card we're
trying to come up with solutions to this
and we want to ensure that we work
towards integration that we shorten the
duration of uh necessary for this I
think this has been uh excellent worker
and this is part and parcel of the whole
blue card concept so that people who
come here can make a positive
contribution to our economy and Society
we certainly shouldn't be penalizing
people because they are claiming Asylum
of course uh what's happening in Greece
is something which uh we can challenge
we've seen boats coming in we've seen uh
children even on the boat so we've seen
what happens and what is happening we
can describe as immoral
we have international agreements we have
the uh Geneva agreements and it's
important to realize that refugees who
come to our Shores should not be
penalized what we should be doing is
giving them the possibility to come
regularly to Europe
naturally people who are criminalized
because they've been brought in by
traffickers is not something we should
be looking at in a negative way what we
should be doing is tackling the
traffickers and ensuring that people
have a regular way to come in
we want to actually succeed in getting a
decent Europe here
we've got a directive 55 the temporary
and
residence directive looking in this
context and people who aren't requiring
and requesting Asylum we have to decide
how we're going to behave we have to
ensure that we are aware of the facts
and that in Europe not just in Italy but
in Europe we realize that there are very
important problems which we have to
solve when we are looking at small and
medium-sized companies and also larger
companies we have to realize that there
is a lack of
workers
and it's important that we get people
into the workforce it's necessary Europe
needs people it needs people for its
economy what I would say is that these
people can help us they can help us in
terms of our democracy they can help us
socially they can help us economically
obviously so let us be careful about
what we say of course we have to
regulate things and we do have to
control our borders so we do have to
defend our borders but uh we have to
make sure that uh
we're careful of what we're saying we
are talking about people we are talking
about human beings just as we order
your passions try to
try to
observe the timing so that we may have
our responses from the panelists but now
it's your turn
Sophie and build
free to go
yes thank you chair just a very brief
question to Mrs hornung because we've
heard from the uh let's say the business
Community for a number of years now that
they have very uh
that they have a very uh let's say
positive favorable view on legal labor
migration because very simply the
economy needs the people so then why is
it that the the the the business
Community which is traditionally fairly
close to center right and right-wing
parties has not been able to convince
those same uh right-wing parties to uh
to support legal labor migration because
uh
okay you you you're aware of how the
debate goes in many countries I'm
sometimes very surprised to see uh
business friendly parties being
anti-migration uh it makes absolutely no
sense uh and and yes we need to take
measures to to better manage migration
that is very clear and legal labor
migration is a part of that because if
some people say that some Asylum Seekers
are not real Asylum Seekers no many
people would like to come and work here
that's not a crime and we actually need
them but it's very difficult for them to
come to Europe outside the outside and
procedure so what is your
plan your message
to those political parties okay some of
them are not going to be uh convinced
that's clear but the let's say the
traditional center-right business
friendly parties
and now it'll be the next
thank you thank you very much
um all three for your excellent
contributions and I would just make a
first remark on on the discussion with
that we just had I think it's important
that we that we have this freedom of
speech but freedom of speech is also
limited uh by the prohibitions of hate
speech and expressing support to
criminal offenses so it would be
important to have rules on our debates
and also to enforce them I have a few
questions on um I mean we I think that
we all agree that with the temporary
protection directive we have seen how
vital it is that people have immediate
access to the labor market so it's
really key I think that we try to to
learn from this also for other Third
Country Nationals but the current EU
system is very recommended it's not only
because of the different regimes for EU
Nationals and Third Country Nationals
but also within a Third Country
Nationals
um and the single permit tries to
streamline this a little bit but it it
also depends on the different rights
that those Third Country Nationals have
and the practice is often much more
unruly it doesn't respond to the
different legal regimes as such I mean
people transfer from run regime to
another they have some gaps in the legal
residence or sometimes they are they
lose their rights but are unable to to
to return learn so how could we make
sure that this system that we have now
is flexible enough to respond to the
practices in reality I think we already
do so certain things with changing
employers uh with uh the everything that
counts for getting the long-term
residence status but are there more
possibilities to make it more fit for
the practice for the realities of people
um and as it is already so fragmented I
understood from you Professor peace that
you may you know suggest to make
something specific for long-term care
take us with you what Damian also said
don't you fear also that it would lead
to further fragmentation shouldn't we
also try to to have more convergence and
one system and Mrs hornung you you
propose that we should amend a family
reunification directive
um and I would wonder why I mean I see
we have a lot of established case law on
the directive which also gives a lot of
guidance to the member states how to
interpret we have implementation reports
so I see certain things that we could
gain with this but isn't there more that
we can lose with reopening the family
notification directive in the current
climate and my last question is about
the tenant pool it is a quite permissive
system I would say because of the
national competences of the member
states on labor migration and also the
reluctance indeed of many member states
to recognize there is a need to
regularize labor migration do you see
possibilities within this current
division of competences we could still
have a more uh promoting and encouraging
policies if it comes to regulating labor
migration
now let me reassure you again dear
tineke
that
I regularly
speak out my mind on the European
Parliament as an institution on the kind
of debates we have and particularly on
the kind of the page we have in this
committee which is so familiar to us at
this stage
because we are growing old in this Libya
committee some of us we've been here for
some time we know how it's like and how
it's actually evolving so I have strong
views and whenever I'm given the chance
in writing or publicly in my interviews
in my statements of course I I make
clear how I feel about certain things I
hear
that is for sure but when it comes to
giving the floor to the political groups
I understand that the role of the
presidency of the European Parliament or
for the or the care for this for this
for this matter for this for these
committees to prevent
that the Dignity of the European
Parliament itself or the integrity
or the dignity or the honorability of
individual members is preserved is
protected
so much societies like arguments I hear
much aside is like reasoning say here I
feel that it is the duty of a
parliamentary house
to argue about those lines of reasoning
that maybe not only subject to
controversy but asking
for rebuttal asking for rebutton but my
societies like them this is the kind of
work we do here
contradict
each other across the lines and at times
compromising and building
majorities and consensus that is the
point I wanted to reassure you about I
have strong views but as I say whenever
I hear that the Dignity of the house the
Dignity of the committee or the
Integrity or the honorability the
individual vulnerability of some members
is to be preserved of course you can
count on me I will be there to prevent
that from happening but as for the rest
my Society is like reasoning sahirov
this is the way we we go when it comes
to parliaments now I will follow with
the line I understand that sales you may
want to make a point of order
just very I would recommend everybody to
uh to look at the minutes of this
meeting and look at the term that is
being used not for the first time
because it refers to Nazi language
to be very clear what we're talking
about I do not consider that to be a
simple opinion just check the text okay
point of order a small point of order
and why a point of order because the
term I used unfolding um Falcon in
Deutsche is is in Germany rather is
indeed a term used by the Nazis and what
do they mean by that to move people out
of their territories and replace it with
other people with foreign people I
reject this kind of policy
it's proceed please because we please we
we're going to pay attention to our
panelists and engage into questions and
answers from them but it'll be now Mrs
bruman yes you go
I don't know yeah you go you got the
floor
thank you very much uh well I must say
that I'm starting to get uh fed up with
hearing this terminology from the uh
extreme right it's even this concept of
immigrant it can be an extremist insult
and quite honestly some of the uh
members of parliament yes you have to
respect to their right to speak but
quite honestly I don't accept this
anyway
when we're looking at this directive uh
what we are doing here I think is taking
Talent away from countries that need it
to we've seen countries training people
I saw a program uh relating to somebody
who had been trained in this country and
who had
come here learned more and gone back to
teach at home which is a wonderful model
when we're looking at these countries
which need this now
on the directive first of all we're
looking at Egypt at Tunisia Morocco
Senegal Pakistan Bangladesh do you think
that these uh countries
who have people who have come into the
European Union
should uh swap what they have suffered
for uh
what they have got when they come here
we've got the irregular migrants who
have been pursued by the tunisians and
by others and really are you sure that
these are countries that we shouldn't be
dealing with uh Upstream so that we can
challenge what they are doing in their
own countries to these irregular
migrants
conflict
s interesting to have this hearing today
but uh quite honestly
is
I think it's important to realize that
the vocabulary that we use is very
important and there is a big distinction
between the legality and illegality and
this is crucial in the context of the
implementation of our directive I come
from Romania and we really do need labor
and we need the people who are coming in
this Senegalese and others particularly
for small and medium-sized companies
so that they have the necessary
qualified staffer
so uh they want to keep their doors open
to people coming to work for them
now I think that what we need to do is
to balance things out we have supply and
demand which regulate the labor market
and
what we need perhaps is to have some
kind of a platform
which will
show what the different countries have
need up with have need of whether it's
Romania whether it's Poland to show what
these countries need and therefore to
encourage people to come so why can't we
have this legal migration via a root of
that nature
there are countries where I.T is very
popular a lot of people are working in
that area and there are other countries
that do not have enough people working
in the field of ID and need them
yes I think that there is a a need in
the labor force we need more labor and
it's important that we look at what we
need and work on it
we need a talent pool we need people to
come into our Lego market and we need
them to be treated equally
making this distinction between legal
and illegal migration means that my
country for example which is alongside
Austria because we are outside Schengen
don't benefit in the same way
so there are certain rules which are not
respected by Austria and we find
ourselves faced with a situation where
we are told that what we are doing is
illegal I think we need to revise this
we need to monitor uh the implementation
and we need this to be simplified we
need it to be consistent so that legal
migration is as it were done on demand
so we don't need
certain types of migration or certain
people but when it's a question of legal
or illegal we also have to look at this
concept of helping people and saving
people when necessary
so I really liked this idea of having
startup visas
because otherwise if we're not going to
have any immigration how are we going to
deal with the shortages on the labor
market one by one by the same order not
only
free but also welcome
expressly invited
to State your views after having heard
from the members because they are the
ones here representing
European citizens but you are our guests
precisely to make your points as to the
views and particularly the questions
that have been raised yes Mrs
al-salani what is it now
you know uh Mr chair thank you for
giving me the word but um
it just came to my knowledge when my
colleagues if he entwelt referred to the
Nazi uh terminology he used
saying that we as refugees or migrants
are replacing Europeans
and to be honest this is a direct attack
towards me
towards all people who are like me who
one day looked for refuge for safety on
this in this Union
and you not reacting I am very assured
that you have values that you defend and
I'm I feel secure with your leadership
but you have to also admit but you that
you don't know us all you don't know
what kind of terminology is actually
directed against us you didn't reflect
upon the fact that I have another type
of name that is not Swedish that is not
European and that my uh FL colleague
here from from Belgium is directly
attacking me
on the same time as he is attacking all
migrants claiming that we are replacing
the people of Europe by coming here as
herds and in millions
so do take this with you that there are
other perspectives that you maybe don't
see but who are represented in this room
and who feel attacked and who feel
unsafe in this committee because we are
considered to be a foreign element to be
something dangerous
thank you
I thank you I thank you
I thank you for making your point clear
I I said most of your interventions I
can follow them live but when it comes
to Flemish I have to follow my
interpretation and maybe I'm not
familiar with the word that in Flemish
that has aroused
such level of
protest
from you Flemish speaking
members in this session
and maybe I'm not familiar with the
background historic background of the
use of that particular Flemish
expression
into the debate
but as to as to the theory of
that is replacement
of the
of the before the of the European or
population by someone else coming from
abroad I think this this is a an element
of our of our controversy right now of
our debate right now is one of the
distinctive elements of the kind of
of of rhetoric
fear-mongering hate mongering that is
characteristic of uh of far-right
nationalism uh attitude against all
forms of migration including legal
migration for sure but it's precise it
the point I was making that much
societies like certain certain lines of
reasoning we hear of them
we hear of them we see them verbally and
in writing and we are here up for a
fight so I can only say that when it
comes to
feeling the role of of the chair
I I feel that it is not my duty to abort
the line of reasonings that I utterly
dislike
it is my duty to to get the floor and
prevent that the Dignity of individual
members may be violated or insulted you
feel like it you made your point you
know you're absolutely right to do so
but anyhow I will be aware that it
arouses a very particular sensitivity
when it comes to using that Flemish word
that I heard in Translation okay
anyhow now we
should be back to our panelists so that
they may react to the points that have
been said please
three four five minutes each about I
wouldn't be I wouldn't be on polite
three minutes each three minutes each
please
thank you very much for those uh
questions uh so I'll address a couple
that were addressed to me as well as
this question of language
um I was asked about uh
the economic argument for legal
migration compared to the political
divisiveness of it but I think it's
important to
I always emphasize and point out to the
public that there are distinctions
between people who are authorized legal
migrants and people who were not
authorized uh to enter now those who
aren't authorized to enter may end up
being authorized to stay because they
have a successful uh Asylum claim or
some other of course will not
um but there's still a big distinction
between them and there's a legal
distinction between them as I pointed
out uh the ways in which you can address
concerns that people have for labor
migration is you can have National
quotas for workers that's built into the
treaty uh you will probably have Labor
Market preference for most uh categories
of non-eu workers
um uh new legislation as well as current
legislation so I think that's uh those
are ways of addressing those concerns
and if you've got you can plan the
numbers of legal migrants you can plan
uh public services and housing and so on
with those numbers in mind
um two people ask me should there be
separate legislation for long-term care
um I mean personally I would prefer it
to be an amendment of existing law
either the blue card or single permit
law maybe you don't need it at all but
if the EU wants to uh say that there are
some categories of worker that it
particularly wants to encourage and it's
already said this for you know
researchers and uh blue card workers but
if there were others then you will
probably need some form of separate
rules that they may be on family reunion
they may be on periods of stay
um and various other ways in which you
can encourage people uh to come and to
say and not be thrown out of of the
territory uh so that would be the case
for some type of rules even if they're
not in separate legislation
um the next question I had was whether
it's a pull factor to amend a long-term
residence law the last time I looked at
the literature on pull factors for
Asylum Seekers uh the the main features
there were issues like uh whether people
can find you know family members or
people from their community of their
country or city or
um uh who have the language and you know
links to help them find a job and find
housing uh those are the sort of
countries reasons why they prefer to go
to particular countries and stay there
there's a big a community of a
particular group of people
um I don't remember it being suggested
that the fine details of whether you
might get long-term resident status was
much of a pull factor and on the
particular points made I think the issue
of Asylum Seekers uh applications is
already dealt with in the agreed text of
the qualification regulation there's
already a lot of equal treatment in the
long-term residence directive I don't
think the idea of a reduction to three
years is going to be accepted by the
council although good luck uh arguing
for it and finally on the question of
language
um
uh first the idea of replacing people is
a paranoid fantasy
um I no one is seriously suggesting that
people who are here in Europe should be
replaced I'm perfectly happy with the
idea of trying to train everyone who is
here to to fill job market gaps but that
won't happen immediately as you know
European business tells us as as we can
see uh lots of jobs require lots of
training people won't always do them
it's hard to
um to run a successful economy without
some form of Labor migration and that
can differ depending on perhaps public
concerns or obviously uh economic
conditions as to whether there's a need
for for migrant labor or not
um
uh but by all means it's not the eu's
competence really but please do try and
train the people otherwise who can do
the jobs and on the question of
irregular or illegal migration
um there's no comparison between rape
and crossing a border uh they're morally
quite different things obviously uh and
legally quite different things in many
cases because
um crossing a border illegally is
sometimes purely an administrative issue
it is not always a criminal law issue
case law on the returns directive says
that it's administrative detention not
criminal law or detention
um the refugee convention makes it clear
that irregular entry can uh still uh
leads to qualification as a refugee and
it does serve a very good historical
reasons there were people who had to
leave the Taliban because uh you know
even though they didn't have authorized
papers you had to leave the Syrian Civil
War you go further back who had to leave
flee the cold war or even further back
Raul Wallenberg handed out really
dubious residence papers to Hungarian
Jews so they could escape the Holocaust
and that was the right thing to do
Refugee law sometimes requires that
people break the immigration law of the
country that they enter in order to find
safety at the refugee convention accepts
that and that's an important value I
think that always has to be recognized
thank you so much
Professor Pierce now this is hornung
thank you
um Let Me Maybe make um for the
introduction to to political statements
the first one is
the question in Asylum law is
um who needs us
and the question and labor laws whom do
we need those are two very different
policy areas and we should treat them
differently because I think everything
else and we've seen that he and that he
bet as well I think everything else will
abstract good policy making
and the second point is because that
gets mixed up often too
domestic workers domestic potential
of course we need to activate and invest
in them that just forms one pillar and
and labor migration forces and it's
another pillar so I think it's very
important that we don't
um play them off against each other
which we do very often unfortunately
to the more technical points Mr
Leonard's you asked on the recognition
of qualifications
um how that could look like right now we
have numerous documents that need to be
translated and handed in so
bureaucratically we can simplify a lot
um also when it comes to the large
numbers of authorities that are involved
um there we could simplify we can always
carry out qualification measures in the
companies so the requirements
um we we could set them lower
um pre-arrival
then you asked on on the talent pool and
and smes
um the talent pool definitely has a lot
of potential especially for smes the big
the big corporates they know their ways
they have big HR departments that that
um
that can place their vacancies but as a
means are the ones that need support and
and
um that's why it's so crucial that
um the talent pool goes via National
contact points and a public employment
services who do post the vacancies
because I don't see a small SME
um logging into the talent pool and
posting all of their vacancies they will
rely on the public their Regional public
employment services to do that
um Mr Sanchez on the um campaigning we
started with the blue card which has
been so highly underused yes I think
information campaigns and not only
legislation is one crucial part where we
where we need to get better in
now gone but maybe she she watches it
later again she asked about the
validation and the talent pool um I
think it's important that we have an
automated approach on Entry which is
easy and then a validation and record
recognition process at a later stage
um also then based on the prospects for
for integration
Damon brazilaga you um questioned the
the broad approach versus sectoral
approach right
um
I'm often a fan of like starting small
and making it making it really good and
see what works and then extending it
um but of course I'm in favor of an
ambitious talent pool and if it's easier
from the beginning to go with a broad
approach then that makes sense to do
um if it is feasible to start small with
a sectoral approach then that would be
something to advocate for but it should
indeed be a credible approach then
um and and not the end that it's only
um because of course shortages changed
right and then it gets very bureaucratic
to update it all the time
and on the question how to integrate
private platforms like LinkedIn and and
um to to the talent for that I'm afraid
you need to ask A.T specialist because
um of course that's something we as
political actors of course say all the
time that we need technical inter
operationality but how that actually
works technically I don't know so that
we need to live up to experts
and the last
ah um is trick on the family
um reunification directive
and you asked whether we if we opened it
whether we might do more harm I I don't
think so if we do a good recast on the
long-term residence the blue card and
the single permit we also didn't do more
harm I think it is just very outdated if
you look at it and it is not
if you read it it has a certain taste
it's not it's restrictive it's not it
it's not pro-migration when it comes to
family members
um so I think when especially when it
comes to the pre-entry conditions and as
integration courses and and a lot of
requirements and those lengthy
procedures I think we we do need an
update
and my last Point
um on the colleague unfortunately I
didn't see your name tag but
um
let me send a very clear message
um we as a European business Community
are a pro-migration very clearly and now
of course I can only talk for the German
employers
we explicitly stand for and ask for a
welcome culture
um we did a quite a large campaign
activities and advocacy activities
during the refugee crisis in 2015 and
16. we now became very active again in
um last year with um at the the one
Ukraine
and yes
business friendly pro-migration is
business friendly so I can't answer why
certain parties
can be in favor of one and against
another one but I can definitely assure
you that we are very vocal on our values
here
Mrs LaVoy thanks first on these more
technical questions and care workers we
actually don't recommend a specific
pathway for care workers but that they
should be eligible under the general
work permit schemes for admission for
people from the EU and small businesses
um we we see that if in general these
all of these procedures are working well
small business will also profit but now
it's quite burdensome and it's costly
not only for migrants but for them as
well so I think in general we see that a
lot of the policies that we as civil
society are advocating for migrant
workers can also benefit from small
businesses
on skills we would recommend not only
the recognition of formal skills
qualifications but also skills and
experience that have been developed
so for example there's a lot of
undocumented migrants who have developed
skills they could also benefit from
training and certifying um while they're
in the EU
and the talent pool and what ngos could
be doing
basically what we see now with the
commission's proposals is that it would
filter people by skills levels and
sectors and we don't think that that
would be very effective so what we would
suggest is to be serious about ethical
recruitment to look at the different
sectors where there's a lot of
exploitation of migrants we know a lot
of this from research but also from
Civil Society experience including trade
unions so our role could potentially be
to develop access criteria to develop
the vetting procedures for prospective
employers and the applicants to
basically be able to adequately inform
about the realities on the ground
that's why we would recommend that it be
a transparent process and then the two
last points that I want to make are on
this bigger topic one is terminology so
like it or not the whole world is
basically looking at regular migration
and why do we know this because the
international the global compact on safe
orderly and regular migration was
adopted in December 2018 by 164
countries out of the total 193 U.N
member states so we know this is a
reality 18 of the 27 EU member states
adopted the global compact which caught
talks about regular migration once again
um the EU research project clandestino
which concluded about 13 years ago found
that the majority of people who are
undocumented in the EU come regularly
the new project is called Miriam this is
also funded by DG research it will also
look at irregular migration estimates
that we expect findings in about three
years but we know globally that the
majority of migration is regular and
orderly and it's also interesting for
you to maybe be aware that the UN
special about returned migrants for his
final speech to the Human Rights Council
in June asked for submissions on the
topic of regularization so which
countries are actually regularizing
migrants there were 76 submissions that
were received nearly 20 member states
from throughout the world and so there's
not only a wide range of evidence on the
policies and why they do them but also
how to do them and the final point that
I wanted to make because Clinica was
asking how do we actually do this better
how do we make all of these disconnected
processes better
last week when we were reviewing some of
the findings from that project that I
talked about on the single permit which
is basically about regular migration uh
to me it was striking to hear that some
of the people who were interviewed with
having a single permit were finding
difficulties in housing because of
racism because they experienced
discrimination and racism my final
question to tie into the earlier
discussion is how much does the EU
anti-racism action plan come into play
in this whole discussion and the
migration policy on the liebe
committee's discussions
how can it going forward that's all I
want to say thank you
thank you so much
it's been a quite intense discussion for
sure because the
the point is actually much of our
aim much of our interests
legal migration
as a component element to to change
not only the looks of the whole thing
not only
the way we see
the whole migratory facts but also how
to respond
changing the prevailing
negative
approach negative policy at times in
denial of the very facts not
understanding what it's about so we
thank you so much that you haven't
reached our discussion but we are
compelled to move forward because we
have a second panel to go in a busy
afternoon we have some hours to go
through we still have to move on to the
second panel so we're inviting now the
second panelists we are expecting we
thank you so much thank you professor
the boy
thank you so much sorry thank you now
we are to hear from
first
Jonathan shaloff senior policy analyst
and then it will be Ralph
kenetsky
director of icmpd
so I suggest they take
turns
yes seven minutes each so that we we
somehow compensate the overdoing of this
first panel on good reason for good
reason for sure
if you may approach the podium
we thank you for that
of course thank you Professor Pierce see
you next time
now please be welcome
please be welcome
you've seen how it's like we're
discussing here legal migration tools we
have insisting on opening applicable
Pathways legal
ways to make it to the European Union
without risking lives
and by the same token
enriching
the the European social fabric
with a more positive approach
to the whole thing you're to share your
views with us and then you will be here
in the second round of discussions
by turns okay it'll be a round of points
to be made by every political group and
then it'll be back to you I suggest you
make it in seven minutes so that we may
compensate the overdoing of the first
part please
thank you very much thank you chair
members of parliament uh thanks for the
opportunity to speak today so to cover
very quickly uh what I'd like to talk
about is this question of whether the
the labor migration framework what it
needs to do in the next decade and what
it can do in light of the aqui and the
competences and the limits of political
political feasibility
uh so first just to come back to some of
the the points from the previous
discussion
uh working on labor migration channels I
think it's important to underline that
generally labor migration channels and
here I'm not talking about regular or
legal but but migration channels
designed to meet labor needs uh are
meant to benefit the residents of the
receiving state they're not about the
migrant primarily so the labor migration
policy isn't uh to benefit the the labor
migrant primarily but to meet the needs
of the state which are establishing
these policies and that's not to say
that the migration shouldn't benefit the
migrant but that these benefits are not
what usually drives policy development
in the area of Labor migration
and there might be other reasons to
offer labor migration channels uh in
exchange for something else but this is
not the primary purpose so if we come
back to the challenges uh in the
background in developing a labor
migration policy for the future the
first one obviously is this demographic
transition and shrinking youth cohort
and projected decline in the labor force
and the issues of skills mismatch and
employers were pointing difficulty
feeling positions
and this is also in light of a global
competition for skills and talents in
which as we heard Europe has not been
competitive so if we look across oecd
countries uh the EU takes about 45
percent
of the migration into oecd countries if
we look at the 2022 figures but it takes
a much smaller share of Migration by
qualified workers uh if we this is just
labor migration so 45 of all labor
migration but a smaller share of the
qualified labor migration I think
another Point uh is that since each
member state is setting its own
objectives for what needs to be achieved
through Labor migration uh and and
assigns policy measures in order to
achieve it these are these vary quite a
bit from one to another and it's not
really worth going into the differences
but the important common feature is that
every single member state
offers a legal migration Channel
a legal labor migration channel for
those who are considered to hold
specific skills and talents that are
sought in the National Labor Market so
overall the EU actually has very open
political framework uh for for skilled
migration for migration of about if
there's a job offer and this
is not the the perception
outside of the EU of an open skilled
labor migration policy but it is the
fact of the settings in every member
state so the threshold of skills is
different it moves around quite a bit
we've heard already uh and that's true
in in Europe but it's also true across
oecd countries that when there's uh
attention in the labor market the skills
threshold tends to go down and the
definition of skills changes according
to who's setting this uh politically and
who's setting this in the labor market
so right now if we're in a global I
wouldn't say panic but a concern about
skill shortages many countries have been
pulling out the stops uh in in the labor
migration channels so there if you just
look around there they're really record
Target levels in places like Canada uh
uh in Australia in Japan uh and the UK
has seen
selected labor migration really increase
enormously since brexit
so the question now is what does the
legal migration framework need to do it
needs as I said to support member states
in achieving these National objectives
while at the same time supporting these
uh shared EU objectives
and here uh one of the the the the these
objectives is to assist member states in
in efficiently managing migration flows
and obviously that's by preventing them
from being less efficient but also uh to
try to bring economies of scale and to
avoid uh some of the uh pernicious uh
abuse of certain other uh migration
channels that might uh come up if there
isn't a properly functioning labor
migration channel in place
so the oecd is written extensively on on
some of the different ways in which the
EU can provide added value to member
states
and some of these have appeared uh also
in in the legislative packages and in
the proposals that have come out
but I would say uh overall that the the
the main one is to raise the profile of
the EU as a whole so that the full
weight of the single Market can make
each member State more attractive and
facilitate its ability to meet its own
objectives the objectives that are set
within that member state for purposes of
of Labor migration channels so it's true
that the the legal migration framework
is very rigid at the EU level it's very
difficult to do pilot programs there's a
the policy development cycle is quite
long uh but still there are a number of
ideas that are in the pipeline which can
certainly address some of the the needs
and some some in a way low-hanging fruit
uh from a legislative point of view that
youth Mobility Program is something
which is uh been discussed now for for
at least a decade and I think this is uh
certainly an opportunity uh for uh
European cooperation it's a kind of try
and task visa to be able to explore
labor market opportunities we see that
labor migration is quite often part of a
two-step or three-step process and it's
important to have an initial phase to
get familiarity with the destination job
search visas this is something that
we've come up
um with some some explored some of the
legal possibilities for this
but in the short term it's important
that non-legislative measures are
adopted and if we look at Labor
migration there are certainly several uh
several possibilities and I I think the
most important one here uh is really
uh increasing the information
uh about opportunities in the EU and
increasing the information in the EU
about opportunities to use the currently
existing labor migration channels and in
this uh the town pool plays an important
role the idea of a town pool which
doesn't introduce anything new in terms
of a legal Channel there's no one who
can come through the league through a
talent pool
uh in any formulation who can't
currently come to the EU under existing
National schemes so this is something
which is designed not to to represent
new conditions for admission but simply
to facilitate the use of existing
channels which are already in place
which already check the the need and the
demanded uh for for uh for labor
migrants in each individual member state
uh so it's not a question of uh creating
the need to create a new
uh regular labor migration Channel but
one to uh
provide more access to EU employers to
the pool of of candidates abroad I would
just before closing because I I know
where uh ranahari two points one is that
fair recruitment is one thing which can
be easily integrated into a recruitment
platform Fair recruitment uh principles
if you look around at the models uh for
the talent pool approach around the
world if you look at for example New
Zealand these are systems which
incorporate Fair recruitment practices
and provide an additional level
additional level of supervision the
second one is this concern about uh
it's a brain drain uh in most cases if
you provide a channel for migration that
allows people with certain
qualifications to have access to a labor
migration Channel and then people will
train for that they will prepare for it
they will invest in human resources to
use that channel and on almost all cases
that have been seen there's a spillover
effect that you've increased the
capacity of trading and these are
individual choices that that so there
isn't really a risk of a talent pool
somehow magically scraping all of the
skilled people from around the world
so I would say uh the last point on
additional value that can be developed
through non-legis measures and in the
short term it's probably to reduce the
uh the migration costs and increase the
return to full use of skills and in that
sense uh efforts to do uh to facilitate
recognition of foreign qualification
should help not just the full use of
skills of labor migrants but actually a
full retribution for those skills and so
uh to to lead to gains both for the
migrant and for the uh the destination
country thanks
thank you that was as for Jonathan
shaloff let's hear it out from Ralph
genetic director of
icmpd if you may please
tell us all what does it stand for we
thank you to
thank you chair distinguished members of
the European Parliament many thanks uh
for the invitation for uh to icmpd the
international center for migration
policy development
um one word why we have been invited uh
we're an international organization
working on migration issues and since
2016 we have been working with the
European commission through a program
which used to be called the mobility
partnership facility is now called the
migration partnership facility we have
been supporting a number of pilot
projects on legal migration ever since
2016. we had a first group where we had
sort of four projects and pilot is that
we also speak about small numbers we
have now another five and we have more
on the pipeline so we see actually a
momentum and that's one part of my
message as we do see a momentum
throughout many EU member states of
interest in exploring and looking into
options to work on Labor migration labor
the mobility there are many words out
there I do like actually the title of
the session and that was my starting
point it's Talent attractiveness that is
a second lesson learned actually uh
um that what we see from member states
but also with the partner countries the
talent and labor migration labor
Mobility is comprises many different
things it can be Mobility for
entrepreneurs it can be circular
migration can be seasonal uh can be
seasonal work it can be long term all
this is part of it and also all that is
actually interest on them on the member
EU member states side and also with the
partner countries there was one point a
second Point
um
I'm working for a migration organization
let's put it that way where we have
looked at Labor migration always through
the migration lens I think it's fair to
say that that has been the case over the
past 20 years or even longer I think
what we see at the moment is in Europe
that we look at Labor migration much
more through a labor market lens and I
think there we will or we have already
today or we can have sort of a bit of
conflict of interest not of interest but
conflict of objectives and when you want
to throw in legal migration in sort of
these discussions with partner countries
you go to countries where there is a
perceived issue with migration
management now when you want to attract
a large number of potential labor
migrants to Europe you might go actually
to totally different countries so and I
think what we will see in the future I
think it's not an either or
but that we need actually both and both
can Inspire
each other
a third point I would like to mention is
I do think looking back and I look back
and up to 2006
um where we had the global approach to
migration back then where legal
migration was absolutely part of it but
not much was happening let's put it that
short and and bluntly I do think from a
partner country perspective the EU has a
credibility problem
and and this has to work on this partner
countries by now have gone through many
processes dialogues and so on have
developed their structures they know
very well what is happening in the world
in the EU and so on and have certain
expectations and they do expect that the
EU has a credible offer uh when it comes
to training to uh and then also labor
migration at our labor Mobility
I think also Talent attractiveness it's
not an issue for the future I mean what
we see the competition as it is always
called and we always refer to the global
competition but when I look around in
Europe I see cities who have who are
developing distinct Talent
attractiveness strategies and if you are
in a federal system in an EU country you
will see that the different regions they
look on their own for their talent so
the company and of course you see them
between member states
different initiatives and competition
for uh for workers for talent whatever
you want to uh call it so it is
happening now it's not an issue for the
future
find the point and we had the
representative for from the private
sector
absolutely I mean we've and coming from
a migration world we sometimes speak in
abstract terms we need 3 000 places and
we need this for now each time we need
an employer and there is an employer
behind to make it happen otherwise there
is no uh there is no labor Mobility or
labor migration so that's a very obvious
statement I know that
um but it is true so if we want to Pilot
and that comes again from our experience
with pilot projects that to to try to
get the private sector in complicated
schemes or projects I mean that's uh
that won't work we have to see what the
private sector wants uh where they want
to invest where they are ready to put
money or into future Investments and we
see that smes were mentioned I mean smes
they don't want to take a big risk hence
why not looking into apprenticeships and
that is where actually there is
Readiness because The Upfront in this
investment is for instance law the
Justice said it has to be simple and
when it comes also to a private sector
interests but here all this together we
do see a momentum and sometimes uh I
think also in countries in the EU which
are unexpected which are not known to be
uh um upfront and uh very vocal about uh
legal and or labor labor migration
policies but we do we do see
um I mean such a need
um that there is this momentum and we
are trying as icmpd we are trying to
capitalize to them on that momentum at
the moment through the pilot project but
also other initiatives a brief what it
was not yet mentioned at all we haven't
spoken about Talent Partnerships uh and
so here we go because we situate sort of
our pilot projects they are not Talent
Partnerships but they are on the way
towards supporting future Talent
Partnerships
but I think we have to be clear about
Talent Partnerships Talent Partnerships
have been clearly framed as
um you know being a framework of
cooperation with countries where there's
a perceived migration management issue
so it's not a talent recruitment plan
for the whole world so I think that
distinction is important and that's you
know when the
um we have to measure that against this
understanding so we are trying to
combine migration management issues with
labor market issues which is complex but
it's feasible it's feasible but it needs
a lot of effort it needs a lot of
stakeholders and it's important because
it's also expected from our partner
countries
there was a question before actually
will we resolve the sort of the
migration management issues will we as
Europe we throw in Talent Partnerships
and then there's a I mean you know the
partner countries will improve their
return cooperation that's often the
expectation and my answer on that would
be it depends on the country that's not
very conclusive
um but it's certainly one important
element to show that Europe is serious
about the expectations and what they put
forward by the partner countries I will
have to finish and so conclusion Talent
Partnerships are important and provide a
framework which also allows for
cooperation and coordination among EU
member states
um but forward looking
um I think there's a lot of room to work
at the level of Youth student
apprenticeship and with our migration
partnership facility at the moment we're
actually doing a small research but I
find very interesting on we're looking
into expanding the possibilities of
student work holiday schemes why are we
doing this because I think everything
related to youth students
apprenticeships it's at the level of
creating also an emotional link with
with Europe hence attractiveness and to
final and my final word is we can do the
best things we want to do if our
procedures are not fast and digitalized
and if it takes six months to issue a
permit we are not attractive thank you
thank you both now I feel it's my duty
to remind you and I'm only sorry that by
4 30 we had scheduled nothing less than
the presentation than of the
anti-corruption package by the
commission and commissioner Johansson is
already in the room so I ask you for
your kind Indulgence kind patience
because we are to complete or at least a
round of questions from the from the
political groups I suggest they make it
in one minute and a half each and then
we will back to our panelists so that we
made this point complete yeah one minute
and a half please yes thank you I'll be
very brief just three questions
um maybe first Mr shaloff
um you mentioned the relatively low
percentages when it came to the the
European Union and labor migration they
also have a qualitative analysis about
why why these percentages are are low uh
you you refer to the European system
being being rigid do you have other
examples from the oecd member states
member countries uh where we could learn
something how do you assess for instance
the the Canadian points-based system
does that lead to more competitiveness
in this in the area of Labor migration
uh what are the pros and cons of a
system like that and to Mr hinesky
um
given your experience with various forms
of Third Country cooperation uh and
given the fact that also the European
Union will uh at least intends to to
Really emphasize cooperation with third
countries in the wider migration uh
context what kind of what should be the
main thing we need to focus on uh what
what are the lessons you've learned in
all these years of doing Third Country
cooperation you mentioned uh looking
through the the labor market lens you've
also mentioned that there are clear
expectations from partner countries and
the EU needs to be credible uh what do
these expectations entail and what would
be uh the level of credibility that the
European Union needs in that respect
okay now it'll be heavier no Brigade
simple uh thank you very much and I will
try to stick to some questions
um similar to what Jerome Lena said we
do have a number a number of different
resident and work permits by the member
states and the rules are totally
different and it seems that there is not
much much Readiness to get rid of it and
have some more harmonized European rules
which I believe would be helpful so that
people can ask for staying in Europe and
not have to make a decision will I stay
in France or Sweden or any other country
do you see a chance to get more
Readiness and improve the Readiness of
member states for more harmonized rules
I also agree that we do need people from
the outside to work in our businesses
but I also see the problem of
exploitation just last summer I saw big
public information that maybe the people
serving you in a restaurant are
exploited and we are talking about
people from third countries so do you
see the danger that we are looking for
people from third countries because our
business are ready to lower wages not
give them the social support that our
own citizens would receive so is this a
way to abuse and water down Social
Security and what can we do against this
and talking about the lack of people
working do you see that if we improve
working conditions and then higher the
wages that more people would be ready to
take the job and we were not forced to
ask for people coming from third
countries Beyond those who are on High
level how do you see the chances to
avoid exploitation you might have just
seen the problem of some drivers who
were on a parking place because they
were not placed for long
beginning one minute and a half please
oh
like shorter than that echoing also a
little bit the question that was put in
the previous round by my colleague is
um we are not the only continent looking
for uh for labor force
um
do you think we're still let's say on
time when it comes to the uh the the the
the battle for brains and and hands uh
or are we losing out already are we
attractive enough as a as a continent in
um uh
if
okay you've already given a lot of
pointers of what what should be done
um but how are we going to turn around
the uh the public mood we see certain
countries which until recently were
immigration countries We There are
countries where there's actually been
massive immigration Bulgaria is one of
the countries where I believe since the
early 90s they've lost like 30 percent
of the the population so
um how are we going to to turn that
around not just in terms of policy
measures but also the
um
public discourse of of parties political
opinion and what have you
thank you
very quickly one question from my
colleague tinica in regards to
um the question of uh Talent
Partnerships focused on countries where
we want to see more return and how does
it actually help the people who are you
know migrating through these countries
how can we ensure that their decent
living conditions there is it really
sensible to to bundle that correct
okay cool sorry one it my question is
about you said that uh talented
Partnerships are sometimes offered to
countries of a region uh to let them
cooperate on returns but you see it
murmur also used for Transit countries
like now it's been proposed to Tunisia
where we actually want to step Tunisia
to step up border controls and pullbacks
of migrants and so these two things are
in my eyes not related and it doesn't do
anything in terms of improvement of the
position of migrants and migrants cannot
profit from this Talent partnership so
what do you think of imposing this whole
concept to Transit countries with a
completely different population than
the the Third Country Nationals who who
try to travel alone
a big super quick sorry one quick
question
um to Mr chalov how do you make sure
that this talent pool doesn't just
become another dead tool potentially
like Euros or others and how can we keep
it open and agile and to Mr genesky
um how do we
um get the labor ministers or even
better the minister of the of the
economy around the table when we discuss
labor migration rather than the interior
ministers because you might thank you
now any other member in the room willing
to make a short contribution no more
than one minute anyone raising a hand if
not we back to the panelists okay I'm
sorry to haste you in this final track
but the commissioner home commissioner
Johansson is already in the room so
please proceed
so very quickly why is Europe not
attractive uh what is keeping the
numbers so low as I said the policy is
open it's employer driven so clearly one
factor is that employers are not using
it why not uh because it's a it's
because it's complicated or because it's
uh difficult to find the kind of
profiles that they're looking for they
don't know how to find them there's the
language issue there's there's a
challenge there would a Canadian
approach work probably not we've written
about this uh you need to know a lot
about the success factors if you're
going to bet on someone and give them
immediate permanent residence that's
something which there isn't really that
kind of information it's hard to pick a
winner so the system which is in place
now where people come let's say on a
trial basis temporary permits in most
cases students so on get familiarity
move into the labor market that is the
effective method so the question is how
can you open that funnel wider at the
beginning in order to ensure that you
you can increase the numbers later so
there is a possibility I don't think
it's too late the talent pool to make
sure it doesn't it's not dead it takes
some patience none of these these
platforms work immediately it takes a
few years for them to take off and
there's quite a bit of work of of
branding to be done there's really very
little branding being done right now
there's no infrastructure there are no
resources and that's that's one area
which is let's say uh fairly easy to
address in terms of harmonizing the
permit categories this isn't necessary
uh I think what you can see the need for
harmonization you can already see that
when if you look at the increase for
example just in posting of Third Country
Nationals from one EU country to another
you can see that the existence of a
labor migration channel in one member
state which admits people who are then
posted to another member State tells you
something about the overall need of the
EU labor market and it also raises a
flag about uh increasing
let's say compliance and inspecting uh
workplaces to improve working conditions
and prevent exploitation in fact for
Third Country Nationals through this
mechanism there's already a single labor
market so you come into one country and
are employed in many and I think this is
something to keep in mind and to watch
out in the future because this may be uh
one factor which drives policy
development thank you for making it so
sharpenetsuke
um
so cooperation with uh with third
countries or I prefer partner countries
again it has to be very targeted very
very specific to each country for one
for some for some country a joint
political statement might be sufficient
and it's more the political gesture in
another country Money Matters and
enhanced funding for all sorts of things
can make a difference
um I so I think there one can have a
whole catalog of things but the basic
and that links also to the the last
question or the actually with regard to
the transit countries Tunisia was uh was
mentioned I think the starting point is
the very fundamental understanding about
the situation in the in the partner
country I think then that's how I
understand initiatives from the past
about Partnerships migration
Partnerships or bilateral pressure you
can put into that a lot of things and
you could and I for me that would be an
option to say well we work actually on
if Talent is developing skills in the
partner country you could have a
component where if the part the country
agrees
transit migrants in whatever status they
are has to be defined could be part of a
a program so I think there are different
configurations but the starting point is
really this understanding of the um of
the country the second point is not only
the what but also the how it is done and
I think there from the European side it
has improved a lot the last years is it
about continuous engagement it's about
when it's about high level meetings
everybody is high level and it's really
The Continuous engagement
among colleagues in the end this is what
I said at the beginning also the partner
countries have gone through many many
you know not only the global compact
discussions but many many dialogues
processes qualified people and so on
um
mmm
harmonize rules at the European level if
you ask me by all means I mean this is
about attractiveness again I mean this
will be a slow process but we do I think
it's showing that things work uh and
that it's not about abandoning and
suddenly we have something new and then
nothing works so it's a slow process you
ask especially about exploitation I
think that is a very interesting one has
to be carefully watched I find very
interesting for instance seasonal work
which is often equivalent to
exploitation we have at the moment a
pilot project actually it's between
Morocco and Spain where we where it is
about seasonal migrants very well known
the schemes but there's a component for
instance then back in Morocco where it
is actually about socio-economic
possibilities so you can add things
which could concern rights or actually
also when people go back financial
literacy or other things which we know
from development corporations so there
are things actually one could work on
um
sorry I might miss something but to come
back the the ministries of Labor I think
initiatives are underway
and it is for people like me coming from
a migration world to reach out to uh to
and we will do and do many more events
actually we have representatives from
ministries of Labor I understand and
here I have to look at the commissioner
the initiative I forgot the network you
have set up I think it was in January
where you brought together actually and
was co-chaired by the commissioner but
also commissioner Schmidt I think it is
for employment and so this is on the
table I think
um it has to be intensified again as a
migration person I would say the labor
market needs they will be ever more
evident and will actually drive ever
more the agenda when it comes to labor
and legal migration I'll stop here thank
you
thank you so much we thank you
thank you for the contribution to the
discussion was worthy that we filled
this first point to the order of the day
with a round of views on legal migration
tools legal migration files legal
migration views we thank you so much now
we invite to the podium Johansson please
thank you so much
again we thank our commissioner
Johansson for her patience we are ready
to go
to the following point in our agenda
this afternoon which is related to the
presentation of the relevant new